NARRATOR: What really
grabs me about this
isn't the cheerful man
given two thumbs up,
although he is pretty great.
It's the backdrop.
The brightly colored paintings,
the transcriptions, the way
it's all carved right into--
well, what is that carved into?
JOE BIELAWA: My
name is Joe Bielawa,
and I'm a photographer based
in Minneapolis, Minnesota.
In September of 2009, an
old friend of mine and I
decided to take a day trip
around the Salton Sea.
The Salton Sea is
a peculiar place.
It's technically the
largest lake in California.
It's located in the hottest
desert in North America,
and it was created by accident.
NARRATOR: But that's
a whole other story.
This story is about an
even more unusual place
a few miles from the
sea-- Salvation Mountain.
Salvation Mountain is
an art installation
built into a sloping hill about
three stories high overlooking
the desert.
The mound is made up mostly
of adobe clay and straw,
and it's covered in colorful
murals and Bible verses.
JOE BIELAWA: We arrived at the
site and got out of the car.
And it felt as if
no one was around,
but yet I could feel
a strong presence.
I was struck by the mania of
it all-- the bright colors,
the patterns, the empty paint
cans that were scattered over
to the right.
There was an old
truck and an old car,
and every available
inch of these vehicles
were painted with bright
colors, and God is love,
and Jesus saves.
I began taking
pictures of everything,
as this visual
stimulation seemed
to trigger a mania in me.
NARRATOR: The artwork's
creator, Leonard Knight,
built the mountain from
scratch back in the '80s
and spent three decades
painting it while living out
of the back of his truck.
Leonard was motivated
to mold the mountain
to share his love
for God with others.
30 years later,
the place continues
to attract road tripper
and vagabonds passing
through the bleak desert
town-- travelers like Joe
and his friend.
JOE BIELAWA: We
climbed down and begin
to wonder through
some of the rooms
to the south side
of the structure.
I felt a stronger presence than
I had when I first arrived.
Walking out into the open
space in front of the mountain,
we were greeted with
a friendly hello,
and there was Leonard
Knight waving at us
from across the yard.
NARRATOR: At the time, Joe
didn't realize just how lucky
he was to have met Leonard.
It's an experience that
travelers today can't have,
because the beloved 82-year-old
artist passed away last year.
But the mountain
still stands, thanks
to visitors who have volunteered
to maintain the site.
And there really is nothing
else like it in the world.
JOE BIELAWA: Although we made
many other stops that days--
we traveled around the
Salton Sea-- none of them
seemed to match the energy of
Salvation Mountain and meeting
Leonard Knight.
NARRATOR: This happened here.
We're always
looking for new ways
to tell stories through photos.
If you'd like to be
featured on our show,
send us a link to
your photography
website below in the comments.
And don't forget to subscribe.
Thanks for watching.